a disease is called rare if it affects
less than five in 10,000 people 30
million citizens in Europe are affected
by more than 6,000 different rare
diseases the information about these
patients is spread between hundreds of
registries across Europe at national
regional and local levels the problem is
that in most registries the number of
patients is too low to reach the
critical mass for scientific research
and studies health care for these
patients therefore suffers from
dispersed knowledge and fragmentation of
information about rare diseases to solve
these issues we need to work together at
a European level that is why the
European Commission has developed the
European platform on rare disease
registration the platform is composed of
the European rare disease registry
infrastructure and a data repository it
makes registries data searchable at EU
level and standardizes data collection
and data exchange
it will allow rare disease registries to
speak to each other in a common language
maximizing the value and the use of each
registry and its information now
researchers healthcare providers
patients and policymakers have a
consistent instrument to improve
knowledge diagnosis and treatment of
rare diseases
find out more about the European
platform on rare disease registration
[Music]